ici vendredi à 6h40 leur est donné
l'assaut plus de mille projectiles tirés
pendant 25 minutes
c'était le 29 mars 1996 il y a tout
juste 25 ans le renne mettait fin aux
agissements d'un groupe de braqueurs le
gang de roubaix pendant des mois
ce commando a multiplié les attaques à
main armée un peu partout dans le nord
de la france des sommes jugées très
dangereux équipés d'armes de guerre
hier soir ils ont tué de sang froid un
automobiliste d'une rafale de pistolet
mitrailleur juste parce qu'il refusait
de donner sa voiture des magasins sont
attaqué des policiers blessés à chaque
fois les braquages sont extrêmement
violent le 28 mars 1996 à lille un
attentat à la voiture piégée déjouée
seulement deux jours avant une réunion
du g7 dans la capitale des flandres
23h30 hier soir les démineurs
désamorcent la troisième bouteille de
gaz trouvait dans une voiture piégée
le véhicule une 205 blanche était garée
presque en face du commissariat central
de lille juste à côté d'une station de
métro à partir de ce moment l'enquêté
s'accélère
un membre du gang est identifié son
appartement localiser le raid lancent
l'assaut
bilan quatre morts chez les braqueurs
dans les décombres des textes en langue
arabe sont trouvé la piste du terrorisme
islamiste est évoquée dans la presse
mais l'hypothèse est écartée par le
ministre de l'intérieur jean louis debré
scellier donc au grand banditisme a rien
à voir ni avec l'islamisme ni avec le
terrorisme ni avec le sommet du g7
pourtant certains membres du gang ont
combattu en tant que djihadistes lors de
la guerre de bosnie au début des années
90 c'est le cas de christophe caze un
des malfaiteurs tué par la police
il est parti en dessous
seul hic mais téléphonique il était
parti en bosnie pour aider ses frères
kostitsyn a évidemment le procès du gang
de roubaix s'ouvre à nous et le 2
octobre 2001 trois membres sont jugés
là encore la piste du terrorisme
islamiste est évoquée mais divise les
avocats de la défense que témoin j'ai un
client qui dit depuis le début de cette
affaire qu'il est innocent alors qu'il
soit innocent de terrorisme des faits de
droits communs ça chauffe pas grand
chose sur les dix membres du groupe 5
sont morts
quatre ont été condamnés à des peines de
prison mais aucun port terrorisme
islamiste quant aux derniers braqueurs
il reste toujours introuvable
aujourd'hui
[Musique]